cow burps signal the end of a marvelous
microbial process cattle have roomy guts
chock-full of microbes that help them
digest just about anything including
hard to break down plant fibers when a
cow lunch is on grass or hay that plant
material winds up in part of the stomach
called the rumen it's basically a
natural fermentation vat there some
microbes slice and dice big plant sugars
into smaller pieces like hydrogen and
carbon dioxide elsewhere in the room and
a group of ancient microbes called
methanogens soak up that hydrogen
leaving nutrients for the cow plus the
gas methane cows release that methane
into the air with a healthy belch
unfortunately methane is a greenhouse
gas that's really good at heating up
Earth's atmosphere a year of one cows
burps has the environmental fallout of
three cross country road trips from New
York to LA all that gas is cause for
concern so scientists are designing
vaccines selectively breeding cows
changing up cattle feed recipes and
using special machines to measure cows
methane output all in hopes that one day
less burpee bovines will graze greener
pastures
you